The very beginning of The Nun teaser says
MAKE SURE YOU WATCH TO THE END, in big bold
caps, I don’t know if that’s just for
YouTube, but there’s nothing at the end
of this teaser.
It just shows the release date.
Then it ends!
So I don’t know why it says that.
But anyways, make sure you watch this Things
You Missed video all the way to the end.
Another year, another installment in the The
Conjuring universe.
This time it focuses on the Nun demon Valak,
who has been teased at one point or another
in all four Conjuring films so far.
The opening shot of the teaser shows this
painting, it looks a lot like what West Dakota
looks like when he first wakes up in the morning.
But this is actually the painting that Ed
Warren paints, based off of his dream in The
Conjuring 2.
That’s the movie where the Warrens have
their big showdown with Valak, but The Nun
is a prequel, so this is going to be taking
place way before the Warrens are even in the
picture.
I’ll get back to the overall timeline of
events later in this video.
But the reason it shows this painting relates
to the voiceover.
Roll it.
“I had a series of visions when I was younger,
and after each one ended, the same thought
would be stuck in my head.”
“What did you see?”
“I saw a Nun.”
Let’s pause it there.
So this girl has visions of the Nun, just
as Lorraine Warren did in The Conjuring 2,
and Ed Warren did in his dream.
So right away I would make the guess that
she’s a medium.
Then I saw who was speaking these words.
This is an actress named Taissa Farmiga, the
sister of Vera Farmiga, who plays Lorraine
Warren in The Conjuring films.
We may only be three shots into the teaser,
but I’ve already got a theory: I think this
girl is somehow related to Lorraine Warren.
This girl does look to be on the younger side,
and with this being a prequel set in 1952
that would make this girl and Lorraine right
around the same age.
They probably aren’t sisters, seeing as
how The Nun takes place in Romania, and Lorraine
was born in Connecticut, but they probably
share some common ancestor who passed down
the medium ability to both of them.
If you’re wondering how I know what year
this place in, I noticed that this shot in
the teaser is the same location as the post-credit
sequence from Annabelle: Creation, where this
happens.
So as promised, quick rundown of the timeline,
the earliest known event is the creation of
the Annabelle doll in Annabelle: Creation.
Which I guess it why it’s called that.
Then in 1943, the car accident from Annabelle:
Creation takes place.
The Nun takes place 9 years later in 1952.
Three years after that in 1955 is the rest
of Annabelle creation, which leads right into
Annebelle’s adoption.
Twelve years later in 1967, Annabelle returns
to kill her adoptive parents, beginning the
events of Annabelle. 1971 is The Conjuring.
1976 is The Conjuring 2.
I bring up the timeline because the history
of Valak is unique in that it stretches at
least 24 years across three different countries.
It almost makes me wonder if there’s something
that happens in The Nun, that puts a curse
on the family, and sends Valak to try to kill
Ed and Lorraine?
So moving on with the teaser, as this creepy
old voice is telling about the abbey’s long
history, we’re shown this little card.
If you mirror it, it says The Nun at the bottom
there, and the eyes and mouth are crossed
out in ink.
The overall shape of this image resembles
a stain glass window, so it kind of makes
me think that The Nun deity was once an agent
of good before being possessed by the evil
demon Valak.
And that idea kind of fits in with this next
shot, a door with the words Finit hic, Deo
burned into it.
That’s a Latin phrase translating to “This
ends a God”, or as the priest puts it and
I had to use the subtitles to understand what
he was saying, “God ends here.”
So whatever is behind this door has gotta
be akin to many of the other haunted locations
in the series.
I wonder if whoever designed this logo was
a Nine Inch Nails fan.
But anyway, that’s it for this teaser.
I’ll be sure to come back with more Things
You Missed when we get a full trailer, and
of course when we get the full movie this
September.
If you’re new here, my name is CZ and I
also write and narrate my own horror stories
here on the channel.
Check out this one about the man who finds
some disturbing drawings in his daughter’s
backpack.
And if you’re a fan of any creepy, you’re
definitely going to want to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications, see, he’s got the right
idea and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.